well let's get to the show ryan reeves
is a favorite among golden knights fans
and over the summer he was traded to the
new york rangers but before the enforcer
heads to the big apple he had a final
send-off party last night with fans at
park mgm yeah rjc fernandez met up with
ryan during the big event
my man ryan reeves heading to new york
city buddy how you feeling feeling good
all right first question this is the big
question that everyone has been talking
about since the trade went down
who is going to enforce the water
restrictions now that you're out of town
you know what's funny is like i somebody
tweeted at me it was like
a week after i got traded there was a
drought in vegas
so i guess i was doing something right
successfully i i don't i don't know
who's gonna do it maybe i'm just have to
fly back once in a while and start
pounding on doors but so if i'm watering
uh my yard on a sunday
i might try if it's an off day i might
come back
you never
know reality check they're big finds if
you don't change your watering clock we
are we are so bummed that you're that
you're heading out of town but also so
happy for you what are you gonna miss
most about las vegas
i think just the people here honestly
they uh they made me feel at home from
you know a week or two after i got here
the first couple weeks was rough but um
yeah you know they've supported me on
and off the ice you know with the beer
company
every time i touch the puck you know
channing reeves it's just i had a lot of
fun here and and the fans and the city
uh was a big part of that so um yeah i
think that's what i'm gonna miss the
most intercepted by reeves shoots his
score so you'll be back in town with the
team in in january
against our vegas golden knights what's
that gonna be like for you when you face
your former teammates it's gonna be fun
i told them all to keep their heads up i
said stay out of the corners uh
hopefully i can score a couple
um but you know it's
when you go back to your old to an old
team you know when i went back to st
louis it was it was emotional you know i
played there for seven years here
you know it's it's going to be emotional
you know i played here for four years
probably
the four best years of my career um
but at the same time it's uh it's gonna
be fun you know i love playing the
fortress uh it's just going to be on a
different bench you've got over 70 plus
fights i mean if things get out of hand
would you i mean you wouldn't fight your
former teammates would you you know if
margie's feeling froggy then he can
leave but uh
yeah i don't know we'll see we'll see
what happens now you and i we have kind
of a past past interviews and everything
i'm going to show you something here do
you know what this is that is a big
jenga piece it's a very special jenga
piece and i want you to have it because
this is the jenga piece i don't mean we
can roll the footage back into this one
that i won with that's the one that you
want with you hit me in the head and i
bled for the first time on television
because of you oh it's over
it's over 2-0 baby you want to bleed
again no no okay i don't know what
you're asking me
all right
i appreciate it thank you very much
you're really gonna miss him on the team
between reeves and fleury leaving us
what are we supposed to do
i guess it's a business but not a
business that i like i like i like our
guys but we're gonna still root for the
golden ice absolutely and i don't think
i'm ever going to play django with
chassis
what is drawn